how did he bring the two of you guys
together like what would he say
it's three of you it's you your your
brother and your sister what would he
say
to keep you guys together was it hey you
guys can never backstab each other you
guys can never do like when the whole
example is given with logan jake logan
and jake to you that doesn't make any
sense what did he say to unify the two
of you guys or the three of you guys
yeah so that's a really good question he
was very very focused on my brother and
i's our relationship and making sure
we're close
and he just made it clear that as you
excel in life you're going to have a lot
of enemies
and if you can't rely on your brother
you can't rely on anybody and even when
we were kids and we would argue i
remember one time we were arguing over
lego
dumb [ __ ] kid dumb [ __ ]
and he we were in the dining room and
we're arguing over lego and my brother
ran in there and said anders stole the
legos and he said
i don't have time for this [ __ ]
arguing over [ __ ] legos
and he my brother was crying because we
had a little fight and i'd hit him or
whatever
and he put us in the dining room he said
you're both staying in this room in
[ __ ] silence for two hours straight i
hear a noise i'm restarting the [ __ ]
i'm starting the timer to sit here and
we're both scared to get hit from him
right so we're like [ __ ] so we sit there
we're sitting there looking at each
other two two ten and eight year olds
crying angry each other
and as soon as one of us would like move
on the seats i'm starting again
after two hours of sitting in perfect
silence it got to the point where me and
tristan learn just don't argue around
that because you're going to end up just
sitting in silence staring at each other
in the face
just sitting there so we just didn't
argue around that anymore and then and
then by extension mom was like i'll tell
your dad so it's like oh [ __ ] and then
we just stopped arguing completely me
and my brother have not had a serious
argument
in years
if we disagree wow we're like okay we
disagreed that it it'll be five minutes
ten minutes sure but we never will never
ever argue we share everything we live
in the same house
all the cars we share
bank accounts besides women and
underwear you name it we share
absolutely everything from head to toe
we never ever ever argue and another key
to that relationship is tristan
accepting on the older brother
that is a big key to it tristan will
accept older or alpha that's the
difference it is a difference but i also
think if we ever do truly contest he
will say okay well it's 50 50.
and we i might pull out this card once a
year of that but you're the older
brother so there still is that older
brother meaning he knows you're the
alpha i think so yeah i think he knows
well you're the big brother you're the
older one so thing so if we're over 50
50 on a call i'm the older brother so
that's it but i also unlike a social
media company know when to one to use my
power i also know when to concede when
to say you know what okay you know more
about this or you know more about that
or you're more you care about this more
than i care i don't give a [ __ ] whatever
but very rarely i can pull that card but
he was very very interested in creating
that relationship and making it very
very clear to us that
as my father lived in a combative world
where he was surrounded by enemies
in his mind
whether it's a corolla with a license
plate whether it's people trying to kill
him whether whatever the kgb agent the
kgb agent at the [ __ ] at the at the
chess tournament who threatened him in
russian my father was fluent in russian
he always had enemies
and he was actually attacked and very
badly hurt in budapest in
1998 he um played in a chess tournament
he beat a russian grandmaster and then
he was jumped and beaten in the subway
had to be hospitalized and nearly killed
him in a subway and put it back in 1998.
he believed it was a hit
from the kgb but the guy was an xkgb guy
i personally think you just beat an xkgb
guy and pissed him off wrong place wrong
time eastern europe was different in the
90s they hurt him bad so he lived in a
very combative world and in his world it
was andrew they're going to come for you
you're a tate they're going to come for
you like they came for me and if you
haven't got tristan you haven't got
anybody and he always talks combatable
paranoid and that's the thing you're
paranoid until you're right
you can be paranoid for 20 long years
and then it goes down
so it's hard to once again say it's also
again like when i talk about my father
we talk about let's say the number plate
things
what's this person following them know
but
that's his world
your mind is your world
if in your world we talked about
believing in things that give and giving
it power if you believe you're being
followed you're effectively being
followed like what's the difference
right so
he was paranoid but he was reacting to
the reality he lived
and and that was who he was and and he
had enough unfortunate
incidents involving pure violence to
know that the world can get violent
quickly and this is the difference
between fighting and violence we talk
about this all the time people say oh
tate you're a fighter and i say listen i
grew up in a world of violence
and i even to this day i know some very
very violent people and there's a
massive difference between fighting and
violence i've seen genuine violence and
it's an ugly thing like if if i
as a i'm a fighter right
but if i had a real beef with someone
let's say they killed a member of my
family i wouldn't be trying to fight
that man i'd be aiming to be violent an
suv on a pavement is violent you know 10
dudes of the machete is violent like
violence is a dif violence has violence
is when you don't allow any chance of
victory for the opponent violence is no
there's no competition involved violence
is just pure attack and my father has
been subject to that and he survived it
but he's seen how it works and he's just
made it very clear andrew and tristan
your best hope is together you can't do
it apart you can't do it separate
and this is also i think a lot of our
mentality even to simple things like
girlfriends
because a lot of brothers they get
different girlfriends and they move in
with their different girlfriends and
their girlfriend doesn't want to hang
out with their brother because they're
too busy having fun getting girls and
all this kind of [ __ ] and
and to a degree your relationship with
females can attack your power dynamic of
your brothers but me my brother never
allowed that if i sat with a girl and
she said all your brothers i don't like
your brother listen
you better learn
you can learn or you can leave his house
this is your house this is our house
you can choose you like the tape brother
you like me obviously romantically you
like him he's your best friend or you
can leave this house and some girls have
left that's fine but we've always
allowed nothing to get in between us if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
watch the entire podcast click over here
and if you want to be connected with
experts influencers such as kiyosaki
tate connolly parliamentary myself and
others download the app minect where you
get a chance to connect with these folks
by the minute you get to buy the minute
or have face times with them 15 minutes
ask them any questions you may want to
have download the app connect and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
[Music]